I'm Rashida --- Khan The
last one is a man's two books It's the poker of
those who didn't realize that they were running alone
Sebun If I told everyone, the blue guys wouldn't stop eating.
I was struck by a whip and occupy it.
They didn't have any luck at home yet.
And you had luck. It's wonderful.
From now on
, you're free for two users.
Throat
[Music]
Oh,
I'll die if it's easy, if
it's a good version, if it's a good version, I'll use it.
I wonder if there is no choice but to do it
[Music] I don't
know
if you do that, it's also difficult for me.
There's something I
want you to do.  And don't forget to move all the gold from the next track
. No one
complains anyway.
Then, if Tifa was at that time, let's go somewhere together.
Oops, your name is
first.  Because it's a manner, I'll give it away. I do
n't have a name anymore. I don't
know. It's difficult to know if I
'll give it something
.
Don't give a name to a new person